el doctor chamán muestra los
medicamentos objetos que no pueden
faltar en su botiquín por ello
y spas malcolm
y un torniquete puro americano
esperan un lugar secreto del donbass a
que le llamen del frente de batalla es
un personaje especial en el ejército
ucraniano comenzó su carrera como médico
militar durante la invasión soviética a
afganistán cuando tenía 19 años formaba
parte del ejército que antecedió al que
hoy combate
[Música]
era un juego político y los jóvenes
fueron enviados allí como sucede hoy en
ese momento no sabíamos en absoluto lo
que estaba pasando no estábamos
informados muy bien
[Música]
en forma y ron recuerda que entonces las
razones de los jóvenes para combatir
eran otras
actualmente la dirección que les dan en
cuanto a manera de actuar es
prácticamente la misma la diferencia es
que ahora están empujando a los jóvenes
a la fuerza
digamos que ellos no tienen patriotismo
no tienen fanatismo ni siquiera tienen
motivación de reunir 500 motivos señor
lo que se encuentra similar pues es la
manera de proceder del ejército ruso con
el que también sirvió en chechenia una
guerra de la que no quiere acordarse a
nini johana para mañana
no han cambiado nada en su proceder
liquidan destruyen y queman hasta el
suelo desnudo
the world y heal y durante algunos de
los momentos de la batalla por severo
dones ilicic unx el doctor chapman fue
atacado por la artillería rusa y pasó
tres días inconscientes en cuenta que
cuando se recuperó aún en el hospital
estuvo ayudando a los heridos y apenas
pudo volvió aquí al frente de batalla
aquellos días de mayo llegaron a morir
más de 200 militares por día
recuerda ese momento como uno de los
peores de los que ha sido testigo en su
carrera wang mongol o bien durante esta
guerra ha habido un gran progreso en
este país y en su gente
y
eso se debe a que tenemos motivación
pero conoces más
sentencia que la situación ha cambiado
los ucranianos han aprendido a
reaccionar ante los ataques rusos y se
alegra de que el número de muertos
actualmente es mucho menor